quelle différence entre un simple
bibelot est une pièce unique entre
l'authentiqué la pâle copie
après 25 ans de métier guillon rue les
livre son diagnostic
en quelques secondes la première
approche est sûre le dessin sterk un
meuble à dix mètres ont c'est vous dire
si les d'époque ou si c'est une copie
les moulures il suffit de nous aussi
pareil on va aller caresser c'est pas
d'aimer se sont pas des moulures fait
mécaniquement avec une machine dans les
travées du salon des antiquaires
l'expert connaît tout le monde met son
nez partout même si les marchands lui
aussi aujourd'hui pas question de parler
d'argent
on essaye de faire en sorte que les
choses soient vendus pour ce qu'elles
sont c'est ça le but voilà et que le
client achète en connaissance de cause
après ça lui de définir si le prix
qu'ils achètent correspond à la valeur
de l'objet services aux acheteurs ou
vendeurs aussi derrière son stand les
particuliers des fils chargé de
trouvaille permet toutes anciennes mais
pas forcément des trésors il est ancien
n'y a aucun souci
après la seule chose c'est que des
objets qui sont aussi collectionné mais
celui ci est très classique très courant
le prive vous le trouverez facilement
même parce que à partir du moment où
vous allez aller sur internet marque et
revolver au pistolet 8e ébéniste de
formation guillaume a suivi les pas de
son père antiquaire et experts également
des tableaux des meubles le poids de 20
on a vu des milliers pour lui la
meilleure école c'est celle des affaires
quand on a quelque chose à risque et
pour apprendre il faut un moment faut y
aller il faut s'investir
ça m'est arrivé d'acheter des dessins
qui étaient pas des dessins d'acheter
des noms des défaillances aussi qui
était pas si vieille que de penser c
faut savoir que les copies dans tout
existe depuis mai d'objets tout le temps
de pionnier des temps constamment sur la
route chaque salon est l'occasion
d'affûter son regard nourrir sa
curiosité en digne passionnés des objets